true detective is back an HBO along with
writer director Nick that Salado is
hoping to have another hit on its hands
after the critically panned season two
so let's take a look at the new trailer
and see what we can discover about the
upcoming season first is the
introduction of our main character
played by Maher Sheela Ali who you may
remember winning Best Supporting Actor
in 2017 for his role in moonlight he'll
be playing wayne hayes a police
detective from Northwest Arkansas
investigating a string of disappearances
in the Ozarks from the clothes and hair
styles it looks like this season will
feature predominantly in at least two
time periods the first being the 70s or
80s where Wayne is on the hunt for the
killer and the second being present-day
and judging by how Wayne feels haunted
in the present I think it's safe to
assume that a he didn't catch the killer
and be he's lost his family or at least
his wife notice how she appears in the
background ghosts like not having aged
Wayne says my whole brain is a bunch of
missing pieces either suggesting that
cases disorienting missing pieces for
its solution or that he himself is
suffering from the early stages of
Alzheimer's here we get a glimpse of
Wayne at work with his partner Roland
West played by Stephen Dorff he's
holding what seems to be a bunch of
clues and judging by the magazine
cutouts we see later on in the trailer
the killer in this season likes to toy
with the detectives taunting them we see
a brief shot of two children on bicycles
followed by Wayne investigating a loan a
bicycle in the woods likely what he was
searching for at the beginning of the
trailer we then get our first glimpse of
the mother and father of the missing
children played by Manley Gummer and
scoot mcnairy the cutout suggests that
at least one of the children is still
alive so it looks like this season will
be a race against time
wings partner discovers some sort of
people the mother goes apeshit on the
father and the detectives are attacked
while asking questions at a trailer park
the scene here looks like the father and
his friends have taken to some vigilante
justice which may explain the pile of
ak's in the back trunk but we're not
sure who they belong to and the last few
shots are of a man bound and gagged in
the back of Wayne's car as he says I
want to know the whole story in I do too
this season looks like it's harkening
back to its season one roots providing a
mind-bending thriller that hope
to put true detective back on the map
stay tuned for more videos like this on
my channel and as always make sure to
LIKE and subscribe